crab feast you know it's all about this
is the crab fish
I'm telling [ __ ] that you ain't gotta
ask me that you could trust that every
Tuesday you already you know ohryan take
my socks off you go above pound cool
goes better than most J Martin
self-diagnose so below this week last
week here we don't get all so crappy
[Music]
welcome back to the crappy job not susie
another crappy spoke that ass i felt
that all the way up sought like a
thermometer get right now what is wrong
with on battery rubber crews rising on
hot appear back hot up and get through
all it is good to see it's great to see
you Ryan
great to be here with you feature nation
Jay Larson here Jay Larson calm be calm
always a pleasure to be with you Jay
Larson comedy on all social media
tonight if you're in LA I hope you're
coming to this is not happening
recording it's going to be a fun show
I'm sure it's a great show to get to if
you can if you do come where your
Feaster gear get that [ __ ] on TV and let
a lawyer you know you're out there show
them some love let me know you're there
excuse me big thank you everyone I saw
out a club professor six vessels so much
great comedy great music great to see
you guys
Boston six July 21st I'll be recording
for Showtime I'll get more details once
I have them put them out and then the
27th through the 30th I'll be in Dublin
at the Vodafone comedy festival please
come out to any of those people that are
in any of those locations you know I'd
love to see you we always appreciate
when we see feet always in the audience
mr. Ryan Sickler Ryan Sickler on all of
the social media site facial Bank Ryan
Sickler com Ryan Sickler official
September look at that blue cheque
September 29th and 30th for shows lawyer
Comedy Store I'll see if I can't get a
code setup for the features save you a
bunch of money come on out pack the
place out and have a good album
recording out there the crab feast calm
for all crab feast information get your
merch go support Jay Larson comedy out
at uh this is not happening and please
do all of your shopping through Amazon
we print a lot the hell out of it simple
thing all the time
premium apps and make sure you follow
the crab feast on Facebook and Twitter
Father's Day is about a week and a half
away so if you don't have a gift how
about this head over to Omaha Steaks
comm and pick up
the Father's Day special only 49.99 for
our listeners is a limited time Father's
Day package it comes out to be about 80%
off with the total packages I just think
it's a great thing to get for a dad or
an uncle or a brother or anyone that you
know celebrating fathers day serenka
anyone that's difficult to shop for
especially guys it's like who everyone
eats everyone everyone who needs to eat
it so simple it's right there in your
fridge like oh you want pork you want
chicken you want steak and all murders
it's cheaper than taking them out to
dinner and better ridiculously cheaper
and you're making a home and it's we've
mentioned it before just cooking as a
family is so great and it's a great way
to have dinner it's a great way to be a
part of your family so let me tell you
exactly what you're getting in this
Father's Day package which is 80% off
limited time only to our listeners to
tender filet mignons to bold beefy top
sirloins for crispy fried steaks for
juicy boneless pork chops for all beef
Oh Mahalo ferger's for award-winning
gourmet jumbo Frank's 12 ounces all beef
meatballs 1 pound of steak house fries
floor made from scratch caramel apple
tartlets which are slamming 100 ma steak
seasoning packet plus get for additional
burgers free I mean it's a stupid it
really is the plan of barbecue for your
dad and then send them this and here it
is you don't need to get anything else
that's a you have any people you can
feed for 50 bucks on that again it's a
limited offer for $49.99 when you go to
Omaha Steaks com type crab feast in the
search bar I'm going to say that again
type crab feast in the search bar go
there today grab your dad and fire up
the grill if you guys are out there
looking to hire and you don't know where
to post your job for the best candidate
yeah I'll tell you right now zip
recruiters your answer with zipper
cruder you can post your job to 100 plus
job sites with just one click
then they're powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else you're
not going to get some random weirdos you
put out there what you want you're going
to get what you want it to come Tanya we
did it and we had floods of emails about
it that's why is it recruiter is
different unlike other job sites dip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them in fact over
80% of jobs posted on zip recruit
or get a qualified candidate in just 24
hours so look if you're looking to work
somebody to work you need to good help
that's the deal
zip recruiters it there's no juggling
emails or calls to your office you can
simply screen rate and manage candidates
all in one place with zip recruiters
easy-to-use dashboard find out today why
zip recruiters been used by businesses
of all sizes to find the most qualified
job candidates with immediate results
qualified being the keyword there and
right now our listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free that's right free
just go to zip recruiter comm slash crab
that zip recruiter comm slash crab zip
recruiter comm slash crab it's a great
time of year I'll tell you right now
things are in bloom people are getting a
life summers around the corner we're
feeling good a lot of times you don't
need a reason to send people flowers but
I'm going to give you one right now Pro
flowers because we do you guys love
doing using Pro flowers when we promote
them and they said hey let's do a little
thing for you guys for our listeners
right now you get $10 off your purchase
of $29 or more so you forgot an
anniversary never done that or you have
a sister or a mother or anyone with a
birthday coming up or just someone you
want to say hey I appreciate you a grand
mom I love you no better way than to
just send out some flowers one you're
going to know they're going to like it
and two it's not going to cost you an
arm and a leg it's a nice thing you get
flowers it's just a great way to live
life and for seven days guaranteed from
ProFlowers which wait last longer always
laugh
recently you sent pro flowers to your
mom how did she respond she went crazy
love them and they and they they lasted
like two and a half weeks three weeks I
think almost broken them she hang them
up and dried them on the wall yes yeah
that's something I used to do they have
a seven-step quality check which means
the flowers are always awesome the
website is super easy to use you can
schedule your delivery ahead of time so
if you're sitting there right now you
have an anniversary coming up or you
have a lot of one writer Corolla or a
pregnant girl at work let her be happy
and all the bottom of the ball that day
man
is there's so many things you need to
think about
but that is Senegal we're making fun of
me but I've added the ballroom and then
on Friday she gets a walk out on four
week I had in the meadow nama take them
with me
do yourself a favor and give some
support to the show by supporting
ProFlowers I know you have a birthday or
anniversary coming up something is
around the corner so right now for $10
off your purchase of $29 or more at
ProFlowers this deal is not going to
last go to proflowers.com and enter code
crab CRA be at checkout to get the
special deal talk about special day we
got a special deal today
playa we I mean come on this guy he's a
legend Tommy Bonds I mean there's a lot
of nicknames ago along with his man up
said he literally nuts that he looms
we're excited to have him back it's been
a long time we were excited to get this
finally going down please welcome back
to the crab feast mr. toxic Oh whoo good
to be back oh wow daddy love we in the
office man need for my gazebo man people
still throw that all the time who floats
at all time to meet my boy tier double
member he helped you guys who use it
yeah Todd my boy he fought in tio double
yeah that was Tom he did help with you
guys for the music and he still quotes
that [ __ ] thing yeah we saw him up in
San Francisco I just love that there's
an unfinished gazebo so well yeah all of
these is the station okay yeah I know
that I thought it was favored I also
have a great and okay that he told me
that never even made it yeah we you go
up some black guy and start talking
Spanish Lee I'm talk Spanish like I'm
sorry man thought use black you but I
had like today he told me I take no we
talked about it we were like oh man I
don't use black key to the next I said
after I got mad because I was like did
you speak Spanish we should have fun
enjoy that really I'm not I'm American
man
yeah don't use black you man hey that's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] what ah she's back now
[Laughter]
so why don't you plug your social me
whatever you want obviously yeah man um
at Tom Segura on Twitter at Segura Tom
on Instagram because uh yeah who did the
ho a British boy named Tom Segura I
follow as many times for gross as I can
whenever I find him I try to give him I
tried to pep talk let's take over this
week you know with you yeah video week
there's a furniture designer named town
girl there's a guy that does uh like
framing like you know custom frame has
some frame where he's ignoring in
California what about the furniture
maker he's also known as get him [ __ ] no
no no I told him I definitely wouldn't
do that just like having my office and
be like that's Tom Segura original right
there yes and this kid is a British kid
his name is Tom Segura
he got time to grow Instagram Dan I
snagged it for a lot of [ __ ] you got it
for everything cuz a lot of dudes who
want it they can't have it
yes yeah we've got tom scarda got calm
that's meaning all right you got that
yeah yeah Tom Segura furniture calm now
he got it man he did it me off you go
you should try it if it's available by
just sit on it we're going to do that
[ __ ] like yeah man Park there Park there
hit him up like got 25 bucks just like
for a low level not getting terrible
about a lot yeah give me 1715 manicure
like I I'm I'm doing it on principle
I'll wait yeah even got my friend
auto-pay on man I gotta miss I've gone
to some sites that I wanted to get and
it says like this is this has got if you
want to purchase it you can put in your
number and I was like alright no one's
going to bidding amount number I don't
know putting me in a bidding amount no I
was going to let that fly for a second
of all let's go to let me tell you why
I'm assuming that if they say it's a
very like is it like is it like eBay
where I'm like I'll pay 654 I think if
they have like a number you have to
because I put in five hundred bucks like
I'll pay five hundred bucks was like out
for what for this website that I was
trying to get to by chance I have 500
bucks for it I just didn't know what it
would be it's like that it came back
like oh that
doesn't reach it for real this person
Wow yeah digital real estate that's man
it is something trance on the side you
know me now it would just be something
you would just try to sell the domain or
you actually just want to know I want it
to have the website okay I mean somebody
out there I remember reading bought
pieces calm and sold that [ __ ] for a
buck
I don't originally but the silly one is
when people buy when they buy names like
someone buys let's say Ryan Sickler and
they're like [ __ ] how you gonna do it
now yeah that net or like running around
yeah like [ __ ] you whatever it's like
over dude I was just so funny Ryan right
here man but I remember a long way may
come what is that to Warren Sapp I still
remember that story like years ago he
said that someone bought it and then
they're like give me $100,000 he was
like it's going to call it like zap70
said here [ __ ] they'll find me yeah
they're gonna find me man talking about
a hostage on do you have a Twitter
shout-out somebody want to hit up hear
him and let's say what's up - at Quarry
underscore Clark Co re why underscore
CLA
RK stop chorus up Cory that's also how
people do it like the other elder cord
clogs I'm just gonna put an underscore
between my name yeah yeah and it's a
free workaround course a free work car
who's Corey by the way Corey is a beat
writer for the Tallahassee Democrat me
but he covers an old he's a buddy of
mine right on cover the Seminoles yeah
yeah I think publication out there yeah
man he's a great writer the cover girls
it's [ __ ] did you go to they go to
calls with you as well nah mags like 45
years older than me but uh maybe 85 it
give me 86 this kickoff here in the
Haggadah yeah man
is the oldest oldest writer in come now
right now they said America tomorrow
right now you gotta yeah super old me
that's cool man I always wish I went to
a big school me too is such a [ __ ]
fantasy of mine
and my younger brother went to Florida
State that's right I remember that for
two weeks and what happened wait a
minuet do you see Northridge for a week
he went to I went no no I went for a
semester all right no a semester and I
came back the story how did I get back
it how do you go for two weeks oh he was
he wasn't even go to college but I drove
him up to junior college made him
register he went in and then he really
started like and it took two it got good
grades he's like all right and we he was
always a Florida State and I'm gonna Lum
here I'll get ya like y'all JUCO black
right here a YUM
so he got his grades up and then was
transferring and he was like he's all we
want to go to Florida State always so my
brother my other brother and a buddy of
ours Shannon they packed out all his
[ __ ] up and they drive from all the way
from Maryland to Tallahassee they drop
them off he gets out gets all situated
he's in these classes now they're just
it's not 30 people anymore talking a
couple hundred you know and he just
[ __ ] hates it he calls my brother up
and he's like I'm dropping I'm gonna get
the hell out here you come back Gibby
he's like we just basically we just got
back like we got a long drive it got
stopped in Daytona
it was just too like overwhelming was
just to over well we was like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] so he came back just went to UMBC
and uh and then went got his master's of
Georgetown later but it was never even
like in my radar to go to like a big
school but did you did you have like
fantasies about it before you went when
it was like when your freshman or
sophomore in high school is like college
is coming up were you like I'm gonna go
to like no no I didn't even basically a
friend of mine filled out all my
applications so that I would go to
college she came over she's like you
need here leaves out these are the
stamps that she had everything for me
because I just didn't know what to do
and know what my mom was I don't know
why it just wasn't something that was
like clicking but when I was in like
middle school I would have like Penn
State and Stan shorter it says it like
that but I never even thought I would go
in me either
on every really now I never considered
it I was just like I was fans of these
college teams Tar Heels you know all the
[ __ ] but I never thought about wow going
to a monster universe I mean you have a
hundred percent because he had parents
to steer them in the right direction we
were just like what you got to pass
what to do I think we are giving it
movies you know like watching movies
about college or ever you have your like
the illusion of what it would be and
then sports I was like oh that's
definitely what I want to be yeah man
for sure funny thing is though by the
time I graduated high school I knew I
wanted to get out of the state of
Florida but I just was like this is
enough
I want something out I was focused on
the Carolinas I was like I'll go -
laughs um both woman I fight I do a few
of them in and I got turned down by all
of them that terrible you mean like like
Universal South Carolina like the yeah I
bet you would see I'd even bother up on
UNC Greensboro I do die and actually my
number one choice was a D you Denver I
actually flew earlier and I loved I
loved this is where I want to go and
they turned me down
holy [ __ ] yeah academics yeah really
yeah no what do you think was his
personality was 41 no more he played
football
ah they yeah they turned me down and
this is a this is I remember this I was
so embarrassed by this one of my buddy
my good friend in high school he was
like had no interest in going but he was
legal he goes I'm gonna apply there he
just applied and gotten didn't go he's
just like uh I got in and he had a lower
SAT than I did but a higher GPA yay and
thing yeah you ready for the movie the
movie is this and you go unto his like
you know now judge that's well that's
all this is that's not even the
embarrassing part my dad found that out
and wrote them to reconsider if they
would accept money and they were like
100% no he did it behind my back
Charlie like what like he says we're
really sorry yeah he flew out there and
everything you know when I flunked out
of college so I flunked out after the my
for as long tau yeah after my god I'm
not even possible got a 1.0 in college
yeah where st. Anselm's a small little I
mean what were you get okay I have I
know but what class work
good to get to vote but like what was
the would you really I loved it I was in
a bad place man
but I didn't are you not even taking the
test
oh no I would I just wouldn't go I would
bail on class all the time yeah so just
[ __ ] off completely
yeah pretty much and so then I'd so that
was that's the first mess of sophomore
year and then I had to do the next
second semester I just did like a school
by me Salem State College and I got I
think I got to see inane and incomplete
and then rolled up there with my mom to
like try to get back in have a meeting
with the Dean and he was like you know
you got an incomplete here he's like
it's not happening and my mom started
crying in the room I mean like he's a
good kid and he works with this is what
your dad probably can happen to you I'm
cynical would you stop it I'm like so it
bears no there's oh yeah I was mortified
by was oh yeah I was enraged yeah yeah
yeah yeah what you'll do for your kids
yeah yeah I mean I get it I get it I
mean I get the intention but like don't
do this I did my hair I knew I wasn't
going to big school because I just did
terrible on my SATs how about you
mimicking yeah terrible how bad how that
nice I got I want to say 890 all right
that's not Randy Moss got a 910 brick
got a 20-point that hold on look at that
here yet is I mean it's bad saturated
fat wait what's half eight hundred yeah
it's it used to be act like a 160 on her
I 100 would be one I knew everyone
everybody I knew would drink and party
the night before get up on no sleep and
go in and get like 1,100 yeah I was like
I'm not going to do that right so I went
in fully rested and everything else the
first time I got a 880 now is like a
ridiculous size study my ass off did
everything again came and I got a 8 9
yes but at this incremental rate right
good lord zuko over here though I love
it that word I did better the first time
would you get a 1540 the person is so
he's look fry it
Oh Denver minimum 6:00 p.m. you body got
1260 by on 15 10:00 10:30 yeah I don't
remember when I got the second time but
I knew it was down so I was like 10:30
it is me too
I was 10:40 10:20 yeah first time - you
know what can you do what are you gonna
do are you gonna do go to Community
College my god dude yeah yeah I did well
there
yeah yeah I did yeah I got 3.0 all
through college I did through high
school a lot to see man I just didn't
that it's where I went test well what is
it
lenoir-rhyne College yeah I got a great
squad over there right that sports a PC
682 man should be to test height my
brother went to Syracuse and I was like
I didn't even like come into my
headspace and you never went up and hung
himself
is he a fanatic no does it follow the
basketball team no anyway my brother
doesn't follow any team except I'm just
ready to go there and not follow the
basketball team he went there he got
using the art program they've like a
dope art program so [ __ ] religion to
being fall in that basketball I know
and football remember and he was there
when they went to the national title
game and it was in the smallest venue
ever and like kids were like selling the
tickets for like 10 grand or follow
their football team does a thing of the
past
Donovan McNabb was there then man that's
true and major 97-98 yeah right in there
bear yeah my buddy was on that team and
then he found out of Syracuse from the
football team oh man full ride on you
failed out yeah so I wouldn't let that
opportunity go no Caroline we just made
up a class form Florida State definitely
would happen but come on down here man
we got you that would be a Randy Moss
thing too you know
when he gotten that gotten that fight in
a Notre Dame yeah and they're like [ __ ]
this talent like this guy got in a fight
like we were gonna do bob bob was like
come on down
so Bobby Bowden was absolute best at
taking all the trouble kids and when
asked about them putting a perfect smile
on his face and putting that little
country little spin on it and then and
then just moving on like hey he can go
to you would always talk about that
yeah good kid yeah he would he was
amazing then but he ain't look good yeah
your mama there's any weed and tested
positive like at like during before the
season starter
photo day so he's on that he's on the
team photo that must be tight and then
he went but do you realize the team that
he was on would have been if he had not
gotten kicked out of FSU it would have
been Peter Warrick and Randy Moss they
want a national championship who in may
be well Winky who on a Heisman and then
went got drafted by the Yankees right
that's right yeah but I mean that team
would have been just mafia so incredible
incredible he made what's his face name
is Dante no the quarterback oh yeah
Cole pepper no I'm talking to college
appalled oh yeah yeah yeah I mean who
played all right for the Jets and [ __ ]
yeah but that's that team it would have
been just out rather than video games
should ever they were they were lighting
people up without him yeah [ __ ] he
was so insane man it would be crazy how
was your team in college my team yeah
that was like balloon cook where you go
foul ball no I went to a lenoir-rhyne
they were there all right man either way
there Lenore rya end like that l en o ir
- rhy and E oh yeah where was it it's in
Hickory Jon REEP you know Johnny hey
Craner paralyze our Jordans from you
folks in the Carolinas oh you were
focused and landing right in Alyssa I
landed at a 1200 undergrad school yeah
it's about in the foothills yeah I know
the photo about 45 minutes north of
Charlotte country road isn't that out
there it's out there and that was for
Jane that's what's Virginia yeah all
right [ __ ] got through that okay huh I
don't miss it you don't know that feels
like a waste of time alone I if I could
go back and knowing what I know now yeah
I would have bounced and move to LA at
18 and like started like interning or
like remember when you would just do
anything
for nothing dude of course I did you
first intern when you came out here no
no but I did everything for free I
interned at Copeland entertainment that
those people that made the fugitive
murder at 1600 and like all those yeah
thrillers when I was I remember I showed
up to my interview in a suit they were
like [ __ ] this guy's legit now they're
like hey nerd like it's not what people
do that you know you thought like oh a
suit is what you should wear yeah and
it's like not people were like what
we're wearing you know I mean there was
a little bit I wish you just cared
screwing like right a [ __ ] every
very good day every day a minister
agents wear suits which is weird in our
business it is they're right because
everybody else doesn't so it's like why
is why are you putting on that costume
to operate in this world where no one
does it it seems it seems bizarre yeah
but they do Asians are the only ones out
here who wear suit and you always know
when they're out somewhere because you
just see them in their suit that's it
yeah you know you know it's an agent man
it's like managers in baseball wear the
uniform no other sport
where's the [ __ ] uniform yeah no
other sports agent hockey - got ya also
I'm saying or even football he's got a
[ __ ] helmet on over there like what
the [ __ ] are you doing oh yeah
baseball these where it's just
straight-up like they're one of them
isn't that weird that's weird
I'm out really small but that shit's
weird when I got out here I remember
first of all I showed up here at 185
pounds out of high out of college yeah I
thought you told me one time you got
really big and your dad even said some
[ __ ] to you not not one out here
you mean Lane College weren't you were
old line weren't you no no no when I
showed up to college like so basically I
graduated high school
big and like after freshman year of high
school of college I was like I need to
lose weight
okay that and so my sophomore year I
started losing weight and then when I by
the time I graduate I guess I was like
185 so what were you tight end what the
hell are you playing at 185 in college I
didn't play football I thought you did
no no so when I got when I was walking
down the Sun I worked at Cibo for a
while yeah peebo I remember one time I
was walking down sunset at night maybe
after a shift or something and a car
pulled up and this guy goes uh you want
to get in I was like what you guys want
to go for ride I think what the [ __ ] are
you talking about no man he's like no
now working I got it no I just got off
man
because that is a that is a track that's
a proud yeah so I got actually got
mistaken never look but I mean I was
that's what I'm trying to get back to
right now honey I said [ __ ] look yeah
yeah that [ __ ] look at his ass is
available oh yeah yes 60 bucks yeah get
anyone to it I that happened to me on
sunset when I first moved here not the
same opposite but I didn't realize I was
walking with that mean okay that
happened me not the same but the
opposite I didn't realize I was walking
the ho stroll down there and near like
Crescent Heights and up past Roxbury and
all that back in the day yeah and I kept
having one after the other asked me if I
was looking I was like oh [ __ ] I'm on
I'm on their [ __ ] block oh you know I
mean like I didn't realize that a single
dude walking by they're all asking like
what the [ __ ] going on congra jump man
by one of the guys like my [ __ ] block
plan he pretty much would have you saw
me man [ __ ] look at the hot young [ __ ]
moving into town we used to see we saw I
live on North Mansfield EV between
fountain who do you move here with I
moved out here alone mm-hmm and I knew a
guy from college that was from here so
he and I got together we got an
apartment dude in Hollywood met between
fountain and Santa Monica is is it I
remember transexual track yeah that's
7-eleven right there man at night we
would just stand on our balcony and you
would just watch action man like it was
like front rows [ __ ] fights sex you know
drug deals I would see celebrities
sometimes
pop out of their car run into a house
we're like that you know that is Patrick
Swayze Oh patty that's Patrick you
laughter laughter oh it was crazy
brother there's like front-row seat to
some mild [ __ ] yeah bet god yeah what
year was that mm - OH - yeah uh tell how
you came in hey man I know you do um it
will change it will change that Mike
Stockman I want it Mike I don't remember
the stuff we've talked about before Nina
do I none of us can run long it's been a
long we're not going to go back and do
the research but there is a story we do
think you haven't told about this this
right here okay yeah I'll see you so I
don't think I don't know you've told me
so I [ __ ] I don't know I don't know if
you hold it on here you just told either
way it's been a while it's been a long
time dry so it's supersized expedition
that was just for two of us in Oregon
yeah they got rented a car like where is
it he's like right here it hits the
Vegas - god damn what was it infinity
like it was us eight it was a bump
normal back and like you're in a lazy
ball I like running I like being an SUV
when I'm in a town I don't drive like a
foreign town and I'm driving highway
miles
I just feel safer in it yeah yeah I like
having the you know I haven't been in a
car and so long because we my wife and I
both have you know like a SUV I guess no
you do yeah so I haven't been in one in
a long time and I had to drive when
recently or I was moving someone's
coming what do you mean haven't been in
one if you both have them it means us a
day I mean like at our Oh Dan you know I
mean okay I gotta go [ __ ] man I'm Way
down here you know it gets uncomfortable
right I'm getting more and more
claustrophobic in them - yeah I just
anywho so I get it yeah yeah um you know
what makes you class forward it's on
that door don't open you know I mean yes
yeah I got trapped in the back you did I
had to take a piss so bad and I forgot
that I put the child locks on so I
climbed I climbed in the back to get the
ball over pissin and I went to go out
the door and they were locked and I
couldn't I couldn't climb up and get out
in time so I'd
turn around that seat kneel on it and
just pissed and I had to how much you
sell that all the way all the way all
the way yeah glad you got a trade
bottlers there's a little I see Bow Wow
20 ounces of P xx that's his thing then
pissing like that I just stay hydrated
then I know you guys think you're the
water chimney I'm not I'm not I want to
put my belt up I'm dead on you say
straight I'd raise it well I was a man I
was I was in Florida and I remember I
was uh I was visiting and mandus must
have been miss not around the time in
the same era of when we went into that
gig to get all yeah okay when was that
woman that have been a long time ago
like 10 years right maybe even a little
more than you yeah you guys did a gig in
Florida yeah it was a Tom call me tight
tom booked it and called me and was like
I got this gig for us it's at this
country club it'll be you know we're
gonna pay as well video this year just
slowing down and and we did it it wasn't
terrible living there it wasn't terrible
but it wasn't [ __ ] great you know and
they were all senior citizens like
everybody and we're selling I'm throwing
the book at him because they're like do
45 I'm like I think I might have maybe
yeah 42 don't ever crowd work ten
minutes in and then he doesn't tell me
until we get down there like who set
this whole thing up and [ __ ] John
Walsh comes walking over mr. America's
Most Wanted I'm like teeth it's like
what it's his whole big at Tom worked
with him before in DC and he did he's
like just let him have it he really
wanted us to just give it to him even if
he would welcome that live in those
enclaves like there's there's like the
masses and there's like a few people
that are like let's have some [ __ ]
fun right yeah set these people he was
one he was like let's have some fun he
was so nice yeah all right [ __ ] but uh
yeah a long time ago now yeah so it was
in that era I don't know it might have
been on that trip like you maybe took
off right and I stayed because is it I
feel like it might have been on that
up and I was with I was at my parents
place and my younger sister and I were
going to go visit a friend who lived off
of highway 60 which goes out west right
so we were on the east side of town
and we're just driving out west and as
we're driving out there we come to this
on the street that does like a little a
curve right like almost like a little
street just to the curb
well you know that the street yes esker
yeah like an S so you're at a light and
then you pull your you start to go
straight and then there's a bend and you
get you go around well as we we pass the
bend in the road my sister was in the
passenger seat goes oh my god I see
something back there we got to turn
around and I'm past it now and going
further west and I go oh no I'm not
turning around and this is all one ways
everything is in one way so I gotta know
she goes no I swear to God I saw
something back there and I go dude no
she goes please please and she starts
like pleading with me now wait either
like is this a neighborhood or what is
this this is no this is more of like a
commercial area and we're coming up on
us one so there's like what time of
night is this I would say this is um
maybe like around 8:00 right so it's
definitely night but it's it's early
night and yes we're getting to but that
area where the turn is is definitely
less populated so there's where the turn
occurs there's a big field and a fence
around that field and so we go pass it
and she says it so much because I swear
I saw something back in that field you
got to turn around I'm like all right I
go I just just you just wasting time
right now you know it's just it's
[ __ ] annoying that we're doing this
so I make the left I think on us one and
then I have to make another left here
and then the left again and a final leg
I mean is your sister adventurous
because I mean that could be anything
yeah she goes but I think she I just saw
something that I saw like a light or
something and I'm like just sounds
because in my mind was going to happen
is like we're gonna we're going to drive
around like oh yeah that's a reflection
yeah our [ __ ] light on that [ __ ]
sign early
and I'm glad we did this you know and
I'm like already irritated by it so we
do we do the full turnaround I pull over
and I notice the first thing I notice is
that where the road turns and there's
there's the fence around the field the
fence is up around part of it but then
collapsed on the front side of it in
other words where the road first turned
away from it the fence is collapsed and
I'm like that's weird and then I see
what she's talking about in the middle
of the field
I do see a light and it's like a I can't
tell what's producing it but it's a
small light and it's dark out right so
you're like there's something there we
get out of our car are you nervous
what's going on now I'm curious I'm not
nervous yet I mean you're walking into a
field yeah you know I'm just curious I'm
like what is that and as I get a little
bit closer I can put together that it's
a motorcycle okay so I'm like oh [ __ ]
you were right as a motorcycle just
laying on its side the light still on
here five minutes ago if I wasn't a dick
buddy yeah typically you were got all
backed up right there that used to rest
so I [ __ ] we looked at the motor so
we see the motorcycle well who was on
the motorcycle and we look around and
like I don't know man 20 30 feet from it
there's somebody laying there [ __ ] now
we get nervous yeah so I'm like oh [ __ ]
and she of course she goes go like
pushes me go go check them so I really
practice like funny man like when you
you're in that that environment of
something big danger you know a scary
bad bad environment but like the fact
that you know that best-case scenario
this dude's hurt right yeah I start like
walking like I'm in a minefield like I I
approached him and I remember that as I
got right up on him he's just laying
there I I don't know what to do and I
just go sir
sir and I I just barely tapped because I
don't know I don't know if he's dead
I go sir sir sir and thank you oh I hear
like I jump back yeah so I'm like uh are
you okay you all right and he just
groans uh sir his face not yet because
he's laying on the side there's grass is
pretty tall he'd have a helmet on or no
helmet he sits up all right and I kind
of help him cuz I realize he's alive
Joe walls Gary Busey
dude the top of his head is flapping its
weight like bring well the skin is all
yeah hanging like to pay just falls off
oh my god I just take on what I don't
know yeah
big birthday baby
oh but can you tell like is he so in
shock that he's not like oh he just
thought he looked looking around like
what he's not even with it enough to do
that oh no blood he's just like like and
I go oh yeah
and I'm like telling him say stop stop
movie don't move don't move don't move
I'm I'm really talking a million miles a
minute because I'm so scared I don't
know what to do I don't know what to
tell him I don't know how to react in
the situation I tell him I said call no
one call she's like I hear her conscious
like oh my god really bad where are we
like she knows where we are but she
doesn't know how to relay it you know
yeah I start describing where we are
like it's a they say West where to one
of us lung we're on highways and I start
telling her where to tell them so this
guy just kind of is like uh like totally
[ __ ] out of it man and so wait did he
have a helmet on that got knocked off as
well was there no helmet law in Florida
back then was he just riding without a
helmet
I don't know about the law I really
don't remember but he did never you
could have fleeing the scene of it you
know he gave it Laney yeah
me and Amanda I'm Wayne man he was
flaming man you realize what he did was
so he drove right through it yeah
when what this is a light he probably
was at the flight the turns turns green
he just gun and just goes straight and
never turned yeah never turn left so
what you got air off that man okay watch
that thing I mean this wasn't like this
wasn't a little picket fence no Scout
thanks cousin yeah so dude cop starts on
ambulance shows up right the whole time
is he sitting what he had to anything
but up right he's able to hold himself
he's an old slouch you know he's like it
is he groaning as you see only coming to
our there's groaning there's no kind of
it's fuzzy gushing blood out of his head
or I mean there's blood
I remember the skin flap and I wanted to
be come over here your motors yeah yeah
god oh you see like white bone like yeah
you can see all moonlight is not neat
just kind of I wanted to paint it bad
man I leaned down and it through the
sleeve gotta bleed cops coming ambulance
missa didn't want to make a little
helicopter they're gonna medevac this
dude out of here yeah
cop comes and he's like hey so are you
are you the person on the scene and I go
yeah and he has me recall you know
everything yeah they were driving and
came back and saw him and so he set up
and blah blah blah
he goes hey man I know you doing the
right thing and you know I just want you
to know that I can smell you've alcohol
your breath I know what he was even
drinking who said to see the cop and I
go I mean I had like
half a beer before I left the house like
not even like I had it you know while I
was guys he goes I would hate for you to
be the Good Samaritan get in trouble I
was like okay what the [ __ ] and I go so
I should get out of here yeah and I go I
like it was it was such a turn-on that
guy out of money guy that gave an
impetus to this ha ha ha
it was so shocking to hear that that
like it took me out of the shock of what
I had experienced he took away your
moment totally stole my moment so you
don't know whatever happened to this -
well I do know that he was very drunk
and I did get subpoenaed to appear in
court
really and that's threw that away yeah
[ __ ] show sappy no way no no that's
just out there for good right now
there's definitely a red book I mean I
heard I heard I got you got summoned
yeah that's it summon yeah just a
suggestion they like yeah we bomb it's a
cigar we see that you being the scene of
this crime yeah flaming [ __ ] out of it
man no no I am this is a story I've told
before but so long ago and it's somewhat
relatable to this I I'm gonna [ __ ]
tell this again cuz I don't know whoever
told you there when I lived over another
valley honey
all right over in the valley right near
county or the city
this was katas LA County in LA County it
was there was a park walking within
walking distance and every year every
summer that dis carnival this is a where
you were I used to yeah and Sherman Oaks
okay there's a park right there like a
few blocks yeah and every summer
carnival not always just go and walk
whatever my friend Christie and her
girlfriend are like we're going to walk
up to the carnival do you want to go and
I'm like yeah I definitely want to go so
we go up and we're we're just joking
around about like people dying on the
swings and the zipper and like what
[ __ ] happens he's you know these
people are just hustlers and they're you
know whatever they buy tickets to
getting on the zipper and Christie had a
ponytail and then lock that up to the
zipper one friends in
you know the yellow zipper the cage is
weird rock she's already tucked in and I
look over on the [ __ ] ground and
there's a lady laying and she's not
[ __ ] moving and they don't see her
they're walking and I grab her ponytail
I got snagger back and I'm like look and
she's like what and I go look and this
lady's just like laying on the ground
like next to zipper we're like right
between the swings and the differences
are high and this guy's you know the guy
working the [ __ ] zipper he just over
there he just looks on the grounds like
tip ticket
these guys are still going to get on his
[ __ ] lady is laying here and then we
hear this roar all these sirens and I'm
like they're probably coming for her
like you're being ridiculous she
probably passed out or whatever
she didn't [ __ ] pass out so I flew
off that [ __ ] I remember I
remember I remember this man bass people
off from the news are from Ron from Ryan
is they thought she fell off the swing
and wasn't she paralyzed I don't know
what happened - I didn't get subpoenaed
but what I do remember is what you said
they clean the [ __ ] out there yeah they
the fire like I was I was like that's
probably for her and then they all pass
and then you know they're like whatever
she's passed out or whatever and then
you hear this honor they did they really
did patty Park they did it yes sir that
came right up to the grass cleared
everybody they stabilized her put on a
stretcher that's what everybody started
going what the [ __ ] discoveries - go
ahead today he's running that thing -
like while they're putting on you can be
up in that cage spinning around looking
down at this lady you have a flying off
that [ __ ] and I just said don't we
thinks gonna happen I go I'll tell you
exactly what's going to happen
these [ __ ] swings are going to be
gone tomorrow like you're so your
conspiracy did whatever I go we'll walk
back up tomorrow we walk back out
tomorrow those [ __ ] away on
they were dark yet in the next day hey
I'm sorry god they were gone no Rhonda
darling yeah those things I've been like
the only thing I love you take a little
piece of aluminum foil I found right
crazy it is crazy really and the guys
that they have working those
always look for the perfect teeth
they're the [ __ ] methods the perfect
you take their money and put it into
their [ __ ] teeth they always would
have perfect teeth are under zipper on
this guy's on meth right he always knows
you know what's correct the crazy thing
about those is like you realize that
ride was on a flatbed not even if like
that is a yeah right the way fold around
and you just walk you
I saw one is that up there I would like
I was I was a around the corner from
like a few streets out from where I live
and it was like this moving you know yes
circus fair thing I was like there's
[ __ ] drifters walking down the street
that they're like you want you want my
20 bucks and like that dude yeah is
knocking in the you know that the nail
to hold the Rope up and all that like
[ __ ] I don't want to get on that yeah
I don't to put anybody I know on that no
no way like I worry about that now as a
parent like I did all that had fun but
there's no way I want to let my kid go
up in that [ __ ] ferris wheel with
that guy [ __ ] running it like well
how do you say no to a kid that's gonna
scream you don't you show no you just
drive by you can't use a cheap on or
like not just always dumb yeah of course
I can go you know we I went to one with
my friends and we found this lady she
flew off that swing you want to go on
she got paralyzed but perilous imagine
you can't use your net that's what
happened in a ticket that ladybug it was
like I just lay there I was like this
doesn't look good nothing like a pass
out you know every I guess you tonight
affair um what do you know on Hugh on
dude and as one of the rare times that I
was wearing like a tank top like a wife
beater really rares what's been senior
in high school I'll do the same for
Colin I'm mad as all you wore even on
stage yeah it did wear them a lot of
danger remember that a lot you know I
had this on somewhere - sure in Florida
don't forget so yeah here it's always
humid we're walking through this park we
are able to chain involved silver
Harrington grow yeah
and a Michael I'll you know like in
Christian [ __ ] so I just black you but
doctors vacuum so we're under the what's
it called
where it's like it goes it goes hardship
it goes up like a like a ferris wheel
but
within the fair is really also spin oh
yeah all the salt pepper say right yeah
so it's like it's going up and around
and spinning and we're waiting in that
line and I just feel like Boop and then
do that from a bottom above somebody
puked and it rained all good and like
you don't know you just the reaction you
have is it's again it's just like total
shock yeah loudly great idea hit it
didn't hit my head okay but so I take
this shirt off and I actually have yeah
ii got it I never had that [ __ ] on in
high school man never shoot a it is sick
it was crazy you said on the ride
[ __ ] no we got it we got out yeah yeah
[ __ ] that that is all nasty man I all
I've never had anything one time we went
to every year we go to the Topsfield
State Fair and what Topsfield it's like
the town of Massachusetts State Fair so
they had like the tops he'll have the
safe you'd like mass yeah I love it
why are you yeah yeah no no okay
so are you being sarcastic I just didn't
know what your feelings were about yours
I know it's home yes and some people are
like a [ __ ] hate where I'm from yeah
true no I love I love that okay so we
used to go out to the State Fair
all-time and there was this guy like
they had like these big baskets with the
ball like a like a wiffle ball and you
had to flip men like it to get it to
stay in the basket you know these guys
hey look at this bushel basket angle
drilling it and I was like I'll give
this a shot that guys doing it two bucks
for like three balls nope I go again
I dropped fifty three dollars fifty
dollars and the last dollar he goes I
got a dollar left he goes I'll give you
one ball for one dollar and if you get
it then you can take a prize and they
were like monster rises and I drilled
that last issue it stayed in I got this
giant pig and like we used to all play
cards as kids like in high school and
stuff we'd go with like someone's house
on a Friday night and you just play
cards and gamble and I would always
bring the pig and I'd sit on my lucky
Pig I'm like what's deal about what uh
how were you into this in high school
probably like a sophomore fifty-three
bucks is why you need to lots of set on
well
was off this kid this kid gave me fake
steroids to sell and I this kid
I got money got real money it's like
very yeah and I worked I mean I had a
job did you play baseball
yeah you did and soccer and soccer but
like I had a job so I was like making
money you know what I mean I know
because I had to pay back those fake
steroids because you know I was holding
that happened to my we want those
selling fakes there we went to Wildwood
New Jersey one time you sell be selling
to like I just had that this one kid had
these like a magnet East like fake
steroids you know when you could sell
them to him like I know one guy that I
think but I'm I to him the what - the
guy that bottom were you like look my
you need to get bulkier he guys got
trimmed down no this guy knew this kid
like I worked with him Frankie Lee he
was kind of trying to leave like one get
that girl never lock for [ __ ] right here
come on you won't be a ho stroke so he
paid me in advance that's what happened
okay gave me the money up front and then
I blew it all at the [ __ ] top he'll
save it back man we were in Wildwood New
Jersey my brother was trying to do the
same thing like and the guy just heard
him it just crushed him at the end he
spent like whatever forty bucks or
something like that and then the guy
goes out of sold it to you for twenty
minutes and my brother yeah damn and
like walk the way I just started I'll
never forget that started laughs like I
guess you probably could walk up miss
those games always hook you though oh
yeah oh it's psychological [ __ ] the
trick they can get you get sucked into
the best retro fun because like all we
did is kids like you just when you had
nothing to do remember when you like
growing up when you were kids you just
do the dumbest little [ __ ] games you
could come up with and it's just a place
where they're like legit you don't mean
you want to prove yourselves everybody
of course there was this one game which
still blows me away
this is this one game where they have a
it's a BB gun you shoot a BB gun and the
target on it's like a blue star and the
roll is every piece of that blue star
has to be blown out for you to win a
prize came because then it slide over
you on the cable like hanging Chad yep
no hanging - and that's like that is a
little blue right yeah all of it had to
be blown out
well my friend Anthony be Acela is
walking by one time and the things are
just they're just laying on ya on the
ledge until somebody comes up fixing it
that long yes ream and they put it in
with all the babies yeah it's just so
fun man yeah
except he won't lie assuming it was
unloaded like we did and he took it and
was just trying to be funny like Rambo
with one arm he just did that ah well
that [ __ ] was loaded and it
started Lightner it was just a little
like trailer with ya know thing that
came up and she's up in the corner like
inside of it I mean he got so scared he
couldn't let go
fluorescent lights crashed down she's
wrecking all the stuffed animals and the
like you know it was a lot of conflict
Def Leppard mirrors and she was like a
wood frame ah he was so just looking oh
so scared just like her old place she's
curled up at the quarters screaming and
he put it down and he casually just went
sorry and the lazy cassava pitch and the
state troopers are running over and
they're like what the [ __ ] and they
talked or no like listen you can't have
low to be be like yeah we doing that's
not his fault and they just told us you
need to [ __ ] get the [ __ ] good I
could believe I should have it and then
this dis just came this is paid
dividends I was up at the just paid
dividend this carnival trick this
[ __ ] gypsy one time taught me the
secret of skee-ball like she worked it
and she I'll show you you tell me the
secret that we on the whole maybe just
water secret you bounce off the side you
Bank it yeah yeah that's the secret that
a lot of people don't know that you had
to get it from a gypsy yeah that's what
gypsies doing with he's a carnival gypsy
and we were just at the Vegas Comedy
Festival and they had a skee-ball thing
outside and Josh out of Myers talks so
much [ __ ] to me about being in ski but
we probably played 50 games and I think
I want 46 so are you serious crush them
and you did the banjo and I would I
would start losing and then I put on my
phone it's in the way that you use it by
Eric Clapton from the color of money do
you remember that movie where he was
getting the hustle both I've every time
I go up I just said play that frit so
you're always going to banking bet yeah
always to the 100
no no you're right for the 50 forget or
that's 500 you forget about the
thousands or whatever 100 is these what
how are they score but you go get it up
if you hit that Bank right you'll nail
that [ __ ] that top one every time I
guess bypass don't worry about those
those are way too hard to green and that
[ __ ] tell you that and Beth Stelling
play with us but she hit like four of
those [ __ ] thousands did she really
really did we had a rule where she took
two of each of our rolls dude Beth
Stelling and I ran into her at the
airport in Burlington Vermont about a
month ago so I get there it's like a
10:00 a.m. flight can I see her she's
like hey what's up man what's up you
know just she's like I've been here
since 6:00 what happened well you know I
got basically delayed and then bumped
and so she's like so now you know maybe
it was two flights so now I'm you know
finally getting on this tug of flight
but there I used to have a direct to
like San Francisco now I got a I got a
stop at Chicago and then go to Seattle
then go to Central that [ __ ] sucks so
we're talking all about our shitty
morning
I think it's her birthday too and then
it's her birthday yeah and then I'm like
alright well you know you line up to get
on the flight and as I line up I know
she's I don't know ten people back or
something right and then we get on and
I'm tired I just pass out midway through
the flight I signed on to Wi-Fi Twitter
open it up and she's like can't believe
I got popped again she got kicked off of
dislike me so she had to wait basically
an entire day even though she was
scheduled for the first flight damn and
on Herbert that's her birthday Pam but
that's I mean if she was in a bigger
city it probably would have been yeah I
know but broken man yeah co-factor dude
sir I've flat coachmen I love that town
do you yeah it's pretty cool I did it
one night over at the Vermont comedy
club that's right there that's where she
was yeah the place is awesome
that whole town is great I wanted you to
tell the story about your cousin who
will
what what happened when we went to Vegas
I mean I remember a lot of stuff because
I left for what the part that that you
knew was going to happen and clearly
knew was going to happen
like now looking back on it very realize
you left that almost a hundred percent I
think people who experienced this
understand which is if you go somewhere
foreign and you're speaking of foreign
land you know where there's a foreign
language and one of the first things you
ask usually not maybe one of the first
things but eventually you're going to
ask what are the bad words
what are curse words how do you say this
I say [ __ ] I use and it's always vice
versa
especially be talking about like teenage
boys right sure so when I was growing up
I would spend my summers in Peru
my mom's Peruvian and then you got up
your whole summer I'd spend about four
of them down there yeah well cuz her
whole family was there yeah I mean like
cousins you know his mom's name no my
mom's charlo man Joe yeah that's tight
shower dude so and then my cousins would
come up to the US and I have a my mom's
other sister lives in the u.s. too so we
would you know different cousins would
come to visit each of us right sometimes
they would split their summer their
summers or our winners between them so
anyways you know one of the first things
we would do is like educate each other
and I'll sometimes with tricks like they
would say like oh do you want a you
order a burger and they're like do you
want ketchup here the word isn't ketchup
it's like ganja and you're like okay
just to try to get you to say that and
get you in trouble but like [ __ ] racism
yeah be like they would say like one of
their expressions like constructive
manatee which is like basically [ __ ]
your mother it's like it's very specific
to the rubian slang right so there's all
every spanish-speaking country has its
own slang so like when I went to Spain
all all their cursing everything was
basically different 100% different all
right which makes sense it's like UK
cursing versus sure here so anyways the
other thing is that like and I just this
really holds true I think for people
that speak in
nothing of a foreign language is like if
I tell you like if you don't speak any
Spanish and I say Oh like we'll be
really careful if you say me Etowah it's
going to if you don't if you speak like
no span you've never heard that you
might a lot of people would probably be
like because they see what happens and
then it feels like it's like a trick
feels almost like you're a kid and
you're pushing a button and you're like
AHA like every time I push that this
thing happens you know yeah you're like
playing for the reaction so one of the
among the many things that we taught one
of my cousin's was like you know here's
the curse words and then n-bombs are
like do not say this well he was like
why because it's terrible like it's it's
really offensive and like we would tell
them like you know that's worse than
saying [ __ ] yeah right and so him me be
like worse like that's exciting you know
that's I want to say what's the even the
craziest thing like no no and like you
couldn't it's hard like when we've grown
up in this culture to express the panic
that that could that would ensue if
you're casually saying that like you
can't express how bad it is to somebody
necessarily who does who had who grew up
in a totally different like they're in
like in Peru the separation is between
like like the races are basically white
which is a minority and then the native
population like what we would call you
know American Indian right and they have
curses and slurs for them to like they
say Childress and Cho laughs which is
like here's different because you say
cholo it's like a it's almost like the
subculture of like Mexican American you
see like the the Chola you know I mean
like the LA or yeah and like but there
that's a pejorative word so that means
native person and it's like it's
definitely a put-down but it's not as
strong a put-down as an end bomb
sure so another thing that what happened
was that he would
we tell him but I think he would think
that it's it's still as casual as saying
cholo cholo to do we would be like yeah
because there's a language barrier yeah
he gaining it of course and like you
can't like if a word isn't in your
native head as like this is this is the
meaning of that word it's just somebody
telling you this means something bad
it just doesn't resonate the same way
you know like like one good like
Christina's family's Hungarian I've
never heard Hungarian before I met I met
her and they taught me all these curse
words and other expressions
did I say them like I can mimic it but
it never like in my brain is that thing
it's just I'm making a sound or you're
not using it you're just making the
sound this time and then I see the
reaction so like whenever I meet like
somebody from hungry I'll be like ah a
goodbye you stumbles back and they're
like whoa whoa you know in like that
just like that childlike thing if you're
saying the thing what did you just say I
the way that it was explained to me is
like your mother is the queen of the
[ __ ] and God [ __ ] her [ __ ] Wow
yeah that's what how that was explained
to me I don't know but I hope you say to
some guys like slash so I mean telling
my cousin about n-bombs I remember one
time my little SEM in high school and my
little sister who's few years younger
than me as her friend over there like 12
11 or 12 right and I'm 1415 and he he
goes uh to her friend did you know dick
Tomey doesn't like and he drops n bomb
and I'm like did like in that moment
like there's such a pain like like what
are you doing and also you look like
when you get mad at him that like you're
mad at him for telling your secret right
he's like dude I told you to keep that
between like it there's no safe way out
of it and he got so startled by how
upset I got I was like you can like it's
not that jokes not going to play like
that girl
shocked it's holding words shocking word
and shocking that you're like telling
her that like it this is like a little
known fact to me I've known and then I
guess what years later he was visiting
and he would love to say it to here yet
to see the doctor people of course it
like you like to shock people with that
Hungarian phrase right the same way and
the sickle at a craps table cut to
before that we drove to Vegas so we're
drinking what were you going for just go
kick it yeah like he's visiting it's
like you know it's one of those cities
are like you've never been to Vegas yeah
I gotta go he's drinking he's taking
vicodin like he's getting loaded on the
way and he's good and loaded by the time
we get there and then we all go up in
the room we're drinking a little more
and sure he had some more vicodin we go
down on the table we're all start
playing craps I mean not craps were
playing roulette first and so you know
blackjack there's only maybe two more
people this is a table for [ __ ] P
yeah and it's a middle wheel it's got a
table this way in this way the share the
middle wheels there's a lot of people
there and we're playing for a little
while and he's getting pretty sauced up
and he's yelling about his numbers and
[ __ ] and then Tom Hey
well that been me arriving and and our
other buddy splits and they go over and
do something else so it's just me and
what's-his-name
I don't want to give it away well it's
not Raul is it Roy yeah all right so
roll so me and Raul are left alone at
the table and he just starts going to
okay be chic and these like these [ __ ]
my god he said it so loud like my
initial reaction wasn't even to stop and
my initial reaction was I looked I
looked I surveyed click like what yeah
yeah I look at my and I just didn't say
anything at first because I was like and
then he says it again I'm like kid
you can't [ __ ] see the gwaan stop big
[ __ ] like at this point he'd already
said so much to him that now he's
annoyed that people keep telling me
can't [ __ ] take they wasted yeah and
he's dropping and I just grab my chips I
went over I gonna teach your [ __ ] car
that money's on the table saw yeah
they're like that's on your cousin yeah
we drop all he's dropping and bottom to
em on the bomb
ever watch the Mexican when he's
dropping their bombs of people actually
[ __ ] get over it I was scared to fire
her yeah I would say things like dude
you cannot use a banana nay that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] us yeah God yeah woody your age
too
yeah that's the best when you have cut
like same ages from different countries
the best too but yeah he [ __ ] and did
we just we just got away from got away
from had to is about to kill me I know
where we were like we're they we were in
the hard rock is where we were when I
got the [ __ ] of what I got did I don't
know what you know yeah I actually had
that thing that night I remember this
where one of you guys told me that I
want money that I didn't realize that
one and all on roulette I don't remember
it and then the next morning we go down
to checkout and like I have all the
money to pay for the room and food and
whatever charges and I'm like I gotta go
win more can you laugh at all yeah oh
all of it no it wasn't real let you want
no we moved over that gambling it was uh
like the Caribbean though it was a were
just a money wheel I know yeah it's like
a 5-2 not everyone just a carnival any
wheel yes at like twenty dollar bills on
or whatever and you could bet five to
one two to one had no right plan yeah
but do you want you want a lot of money
on and kept it northern dozens racist
over there roulette he's over there
banking up on the money we roofing is
dropping and bombs in a pitch is loud at
a crowded ass [ __ ] table with me
standing next to them and he knew I was
with them because I've been there a
while so yes let me know now I'm this
guy's done on numbers with 27 I got
ain't nobody to look over at you oh man
I just felt like the heat I got all hot
I just gathered my chips I was like I'm
getting the [ __ ] out of here man if I
have a nice really I would put it all
black but if I stood next to him for
that
I told him I kept saying akiza was not
made [ __ ] India I'm like all you're
about to find out what the big [ __ ]
deal is I'm telling you you don't to say
it you know like it's not going to be
just me telling you not do it anymore
some part of it like some part of it you
go
like if if it's if somebody was like
never say goodbye here you're like your
drink first thing I'm like yeah yeah and
you just wait for people yeah back to
you that's exactly what happened yeah
plus he was getting mad he was losing
money so now he's gonna say whatever the
[ __ ] he wants you know he was it's four
hours of drinking and some pills and I'm
there plus mix of racism yeah I didn't
know God yeah you never even think of it
like that you're right
we hadn't learned something you know
even the words that we do know like you
know when you're under like a little kid
or at least when I used to before I had
kids like my cousin he was like three
and I'd be around like hey [ __ ] came to
tell you [ __ ] let me go the other like
[ __ ] and they'd be like what's up yeah
yeah yeah I mean it's not the same but
yeah you get it is it it is a repeating
the thing yard yeah let's see what
happened yeah let's roll the dice yeah
literally
hey guys not well look man we're there
we're out of time here this has been a
lot of [ __ ] shot how long was that
blow over now okay
[ __ ] that's fun man can we do it more
often than every I mean yeah that'd be
nice well last time don't forget I know
it supposed to be a while ago you know I
mean they uphill I got [ __ ] to do and
then you know I was the new canceled
like toys I did yeah your parents
Charlie man trial came it all came into
town she can't she's dropping bombs all
week so there was a big [ __ ] deal
coming up ha ha your cousin's right I
had them on my podcast who your cousin
below no parents oh yeah yeah how was
that there's a lot of I mean we didn't
set it up like you do I was like come
here sit down and just talk and it was
fun man there's really really fun out
there
they're ridiculous couple I'm sure
they're ridiculous my dad breathing the
whole time in the way like a you so
[ __ ] stop doing what you're bleeding
like go dude did they listen to the
podcast Tom they know I get it you have
your dad on a lotto by call he called ah
yeah yeah yeah but he doesn't listen to
his episodes he's not that guy now he he
would listen to an i
related file in a moment I play at
museum clips yes semi clips and and oh
he also today I was like I'm going to do
because yes I was doing like I'm going
to French pocket now if you do their
podcast he's like your listeners will
have to decide who to listen to
I go why and he's like because he he's
like cuz I wanna show is on can't watch
two shows same time when I go it's not
airing live on demand I never thought
about that
hmm we had my mom on how is that I was
awesome I was awesome she was in here
yeah and she was [ __ ] great she came
with stories everything I did a great
ones she listened yeah yes yeah she was
assaulted a week I mean that's a
brown-nose me bald long but you guys oh
yeah I'll tell you this we I mean we've
told but I wouldn't mind telling Tom but
my mom came on and she crushed it and so
she said to my brother recently I think
I should maybe being a recurring guest
on the show I did very well he did well
she was here just his last time we were
trying to have her again but we could
make it work out I got I got to tell you
that my dad so they were in there for
over an hour my parents and we did like
we played some would you rather
scenarios talked they took it all is
your mom occult oh yeah she had you
disgusted by him they are all the time
he's like I got big fart and she's like
disgusting but then we leave there and
we walk into the living room and my dad
goes oh really just a natural this I'm
like what just good at this you know I
just I like the spot like I'm good at it
I'm like dude you don't even know like
I'm just gonna let you live another
minute
yeah but he's just like talking about
how good he is at it that's unbelievable
my mom loved it you ready so my mom she
calls me up one day she goes well listen
to this
she's like I'm at the coffee our church
on Sunday and one of the women in her
church I guess had been flying and they
lost her bags and they got home to call
Delta and she's on the phone with Delta
and the guy
like all right well we have your bags we
can send them out and she's like okay
great and she goes what's your address
and she gives her address yada yada yada
Stoneham Massachusetts Oh to18 oh and
the guy goes stone cheese yeah he goes
she knew Jane Larson from the crab and
she goes well I I know his mother and go
sue Larson from the brat from the crab
feast ha ha ha ha that's amazing this
woman told my mom and my mom just like I
mean I I'm a little bit of a celebrity
yeah of course went ahead when we did
our fault or we did our stop in Boston
and she came she brought a bunch of
girlfriends and when she came out to the
lobby she signed autograph when we
started the shed we go up together and
we Hawk and we called up my mom she
stood in the Polly didn't door you went
[ __ ] nuts for her he told that story
and then the place went nuts for my mom
she's like yeah and then she was in the
line taking pictures of siding
autographed everything ha ha ha ha
people would read it wanted to come
after oh yeah they really did I think I
think it would over well in my day if he
went to a live podcast doesn't sound
like it now probably know I didn't work
I mean I think it would just inflate
like he would be like when is the next
one like he was gonna be a drug out of
would be yeah
have they been to your show lately
they've been to a couple yeah they flew
to a Jersey and they went to the Borgata
one and what do they think I think my I
think my mom watches the show
I think my dad watches the audience
watch the show yeah you know like they
really liked that one I'm like you
talked to give notes and [ __ ] he'll now
he'll be like he'll talk about things he
likes like he'll be like like that that
was a really good thing there and then
I'll think about the thing I don't think
he likes just to hear him be like yeah
I'm gonna get that I mean what that's
what we do when we see someone in the
audience like just kind of having a good
time just [ __ ] hone in on that guy
yeah well when we do Baltimore together
my mother was I mean she pushed my CDs
off the table to get the talent Agora
right I've heard that we know thought
about merger her favorite song Erica
Alzheimer
is it amazing the way faint like one
time I had an aunt come to a show and I
think afterwards maybe my mom was like
so how was it
she's like oh so great
she's like isn't Tommy great and she was
like they were both great and she was
like like my aunt couldn't give me the
cops she had to be like yeah she's like
I really just enjoyed everybody I was
like wow but why wouldn't you just lie
yes he's not here Yeah right lie yeah
and she was like then they were both
good see my mom will always just be like
you were fantastic Jason at that point
though cuz when parents do that then you
know much exactly I look back yeah my
brother's cutthroat with his criticism
he is yeah like so like he never
compliments anything that I do nothing
like a pocket nothing of the game
another guy told me this is your
podcaster day and then that's it
yeah that's nice you know like you must
be I guess at the end of the thought you
know so he went to this play with his
wife and it's something like his wife
worked with the the lady that was in the
play her husband was also in the place
this married couple acts in this play
they're going to see the play and the
wife she had had I don't know if we took
some time off or but it was like her
first time back but the husband had been
you know at it so at the end of the play
my brother staying there with his wife
in the lobby and they come out and he's
like she's like oh my god you were so
good so good once you good there's again
you're alright but he was great I saw em
I said she got all the photos tell him
he's like I understand why that's a big
deal and I'm like God how do you not see
that like she's explaining it to him
Ryan I go it's so [ __ ] rude and so
but but I'm laughing doesn't really get
it does it but not also just like
toughen the [ __ ] up I gave you a
compliment right this gave him a nicer
comp right
I mean and he but he couldn't see why we
always talk about do you ever have the
person that goes uh they come up see and
they're like that was pretty funny
you're like how do you qualify it right
like just say don't say anything or just
say like that was funny yeah or really
but why would you say don't know how to
it's like the same thing of like I was
compared to like someone being like
you're pretty pretty good-looking like
you would be like what the [ __ ] yeah I'm
good for no no eiga though like you to
dial it down to that and they all it's
not you know tons of them but there's
always the guy it's just a guy it's
always a guy was like that was pretty
funny see I always go sound like oh
pretty funny huh it's pretty funny yeah
I man thanks for coming you know they're
like oh I meant family yeah he was
addicted me yes they say all got it yeah
when we were home my mom had us over for
dinner
yeah and she's like cooked this huge
meal for I than Italian dinner right
yeah so like we get there and just me
and Ryan that my sister's coming with
her kids and stuff and my brother she's
one night away from basking in the glow
her big her big performance at the club
right yeah you know so she's on a high
yeah we were at my brothers in the city
before and I said hey you coming to
mom's ignite good rise like well she's
cook a big feast man said she's making
meatballs and my brother goes hey heads
up heads up with those meatballs and
Rygel's be talking about like last time
I was there rare in the middle
and he goes same with her scalps watch
out she's making scallops so we get over
there that's like a 1 o'clock if you
have to do morning for dinner yeah yeah
so we get over there my mom shown right
around the house she comes to the
kitchen she's like well look what I have
for you Ryan I have I've homemade
meatballs I have I made a homemade sauce
and I go you didn't make that sauce she
goes yes I did
I might you made this sauce from scratch
she was yeah I'm like okay and she goes
eggplant parm that's not my recipe and
which it was out of a box it was so like
salon so or so yeah it was the best
thing in the bench it's [ __ ]
microwave so then she's like point
Africa what else we were having a bunch
of stuff but no bridge a road or about
I'm not yet - yeah so then she goes let
me show you the rest of us like a well
hold on a second before we go any
further I'm like you to make that sauce
she was yes we did I go ma I know you
didn't make the sauce she goes Jayson
yes that is
I made that song ago I'm not gonna let
you show Ryan the rest of the house
until you admit you did make that sauce
and she goes half it was mine and I ran
out of the jars well okay
which means it wasn't it wasn't a
thought so we say that like a
characteristic that she would always do
that though no it's very funny I never
knew my mom to make sauce my Nana made
us mine I know but from my point of view
he's riding high like it's a wonderful
weekend right her like I made homemade
sauce I'm throwing you this big meal you
know yeah like it was all coming from
such a great place but yeah he knows his
mom you know I'm gonna push her all that
way so then like anyway my sister shows
up we all hang out then it's time for
dinner every once in a diamond-like al
let me help you with all the food you
know so I'm bringing everything in
everyone sitting down to start from
their plates the last thing as the
meatballs I look at my mom like hold on
a second she's like what I'm like let me
check this meatball she's like what are
you talking about I go hold on I cut one
open
sure enough rare rare in the middle I go
MA
she's like what I go it's rare in the
middle she goes what that's what what do
you want me to do Jason I go you can't
[ __ ] sir summarize just don't talk to
me like that and I go ma it's rare she
goes whoa what do you want to do and I
go all right I go up to the table and
again none of us at the table or privy
to that right right right yeah so I put
the meatballs down and then you gotta go
around through the living room to get to
my seat right because the dining room is
like too narrow to get through so I go
down I sit in my seat and I said tango
hey just a heads up those meatballs are
rare in the middle
do what you will with them now rise
already served himself a meatball but J
looked at me and he denied service of me
I was excited to get the meatball and he
just looked at me dead serious and he
just went
be careful but like I was handling a
king crab looked like he was like be
careful huh no one else took the
meatballs no one rides only wanted took
a meatball and he ate around that middle
and them he did I cut that video but all
there oh and I just it was like I'm
mourning an edge to brown around it you
know to me and then I mashed it off in
my sauce so you cuz I buried it about
that power zones go right back man it
was that good to that what if my mom
rides it next to my mom what did she say
like how phone
like he I didn't know that he had busted
her balls out in the kitchen but she
that when they came by she took them and
passed them and she's sitting right and
she just meatballs are delicious like
out loud that herself out of s so then
that [ __ ] gave me I had the worst um is
really that I mean come on hold on from
that your ass blows out once oh no
farting belching like tasting that all
come back up from his [ __ ] roll meat
yeah so then later so like a week later
I talk to my mom and I was like those
meatballs ma huh well I go over here
she's like I could have killed you that
night nothing's wrong with a medium-rare
meatball haven't you ever had a
medium-rare hamburger and I was just
like you know that logic part of me
wanted like yeah oh she's kind of right
but anytime I go wrong different with me
that is always different all wrong
anyway next time you go do Boston I let
my mom know you go by the house for a
hotel Samia cries just just send her out
its to fill the Thunder man come out
this way alright yeah I'd love to meet
her though yeah she loved honeymoon to
Larson de cría fees is great and I just
make talented at this oh look man thank
you for being here it's been a lot of
fun thanks for having me guys I'm always
a pleasure buddy promote one more time
whatever you'd like please I have a I'm
announcing my my fall dates go on sale
June 9th so if you go to Tom Segura
dot-com slash tour I'm adding like 25
cities so rates a bunch of bunch of
dates are on sale now cities you've
never been to or you're going back to
some are new some are going back
Baltimore in July Baltimore in July it's
almost done man
almost sold out and advertise them dude
good for you man I'm stoked for you all
the things going good in your life and I
stuck to have you on as always Jay
Larson comma calm Jay Larson comedy on
all social media Ryan Sickler comm Ryan
Sickler on all social media talkie all
next Tuesday